since 1967 cea Letty here in Grenoble in
the southeast of France has been one of
the world's largest research hubs for
electronics and nanotechnology and by
the mid-2000s the folks here had a
problem they had two clean rooms two
carefully controlled spaces with
purified air where research and testing
could be done without any dust or
contaminants getting in the way but
those two clean rooms were 250 meters
apart on opposite sides of a road which
is the kind of thing that happens when
your campus steadily grows over decades
so every time some tiny component or
piece of equipment needed to be moved
from one to the other it had to be put
in sterile packaging then the
researchers would have to leave the
clean room take off all the gowns and
gloves and shoe covers walk over put on
a whole new set of protective gear clean
off the packaging and then finally go in
and unpack it and you can see the
solution they built the world's cleanest
people mover a clean room on wheels that
can somehow Dock and undocked the main
buildings without letting any outside
airing
and we're going for a ride the clean
room is about 11
000 square meter today atleti we have
about 2 000 employees and 800 of them
are focusing on fabrication we are
making devices from components to
sensors and we are mixing a wide variety
of Technologies including lasers Quantum
Technologies we are able to print
circuits down to the 10 nanometer nodes
this is the device that you will find in
your phone or in drones and specific
systems to speak about the dimension we
said that the thickness of one hair is
about 50 Micron so when we discuss a
transistor with a dimension of 10
nanometer it's about 5 000 times smaller
than the hair and the risk is that when
one hair is dropping on the surface that
of course the circuit won't operate all
the horrible human stuff is sealed
inside many layers Let's uh let's go
ride a people mover we have to operate
in very clean environment since the
source of contamination is as so
basically we have to wear a special
clothes to protect the Wafers and the
dies and the circuits and the
nanotransisters from us obvious question
why not just build a corridor well they
did think about it but that's a colossal
amount of space that would have to be
filled with ventilation and air
treatment equipment all the way along
all constantly running and maintained at
huge expense
also they were worried about how people
would feel walking down an isolated
empty narrow sealed in 250 meter
Corridor with no doors where you can't
see the other end because it needs steps
in the middle to get over the road not
great
oh there's the buttons someone should
probably join me in here how clean is a
clean room I would say compared to the
hospital and the surgical theater the
surgical theater has probably 100 times
more particles in the air and I would
say that the house has probably one
million times more particles in the air
we can see these big gray pipes and this
is the way that we are operating the
recirculation of the air from the top to
the basement through the bin rooms I
should point out this there's three or
four people crowded behind the camera
here I'm I'm not being allowed in the
clean room funicular on my own
here we go
and this is a clean room the air is
still being circulated just as it was in
each of the buildings the concrete
supports that we're traveling over and
all the powered systems that are hauling
the cables that are moving us are well
they're not off the shelf but they are
about as standard as you can get for
something like this they're manufactured
by a company called coma who make all
sorts of roadways for this clean room
that sits on the top or making this work
was up to the folks in the cea to
independum we have a special team which
take care of the cleaning of the
surfaces and make sure that no particles
are stuck we have to clean the shuttle
as well so the cleaning team is also
operating within the shuttle the problem
is that this has to adopt and undock
from the clean rooms how does Dustin
outside air not get inside
the cabin slows down a lot at the end of
its run and that's because it has to
position itself extremely carefully
millimeter accurate to make sure the
Rubber seal on this door matches up with
a rubber seal on the door of the clean
room they get connected and then high
pressure air blasts out anything in
between all the outside atmosphere is
exhausted by fresh clean air and this
whole system the People Mover and the
clean room is kept at a slightly higher
pressure than the outside so if that
ever is a leak it's only going to leak
outwards when you enter the shuttle the
door will close and then you have to
wait for maybe 30 seconds before there
is a higher pressure inside and then at
the end we have the same operation it's
to depressurize the shuttle to allow the
door to open and the operator to move in
the next clean home facility so why not
just let people keep over the old
for this was installed the researchers
here estimated that transporting stuff
between the two rooms was so inefficient
that it lost the time equivalent of
seven or eight full-time jobs and
rebuilding the clean rooms would cost
far far more this might seem a bit
unnecessary at first but out of
everything
it's probably the least expensive option
foreign
I can't do the walk off into the
distance I'm not allowed through this my
badge doesn't let me
we uh we go back let's let's go back